imaginez une famille regardait la
télévision tous les soirs au début il
n'y a qu'une poignée de chaîne 6 pour
être précis mais tout à coup l'offre
audiovisuelle explose si bien que la
famille passe désormais ses soirées à
zapper d'une chaîne à l'autre cependant
rapidement il y a désormais des milliers
de chaînes si bien que la plupart des
chaînes ne sont en fait jamais explorées
par la famille pour mieux profiter de
l’offre audiovisuelle la famille
souscrit alors un service zapping toutes
les demi-heures le service de zapping
change de chaîne pour découvrir d'autres
émissions au début la famille trouve ce
service étrange mais petit à petit elle
s'y fait et reconnaît que le service est
finalement en meilleur pour trouver des
émissions innovantes et distrayantes que
l'effort laborieux de zapping manuel
certes il arrive souvent que la famille
n'apprécie pas le zapping proposé mais
elle peut alors modifier elle-même la
chaîne alors sélectionnée cependant il
lui en fait plus simple encore de
demander au service de zapping de zapper
à sa place vers une autre chaîne ceci
étant dit moi après moi le service de
zapping apprend les préférences de la
famille et son zapping est de plus en
plus conforme aux préférences de la
famille dès lors petit à petit la
famille réagit de moins en moins lorsque
le service zapping change le contenu
audiovisuel qu'elle consomme et au fur
et à mesure que ce service s'améliore il
s'accélère également avec un zapping
toutes les 5 minutes et même pour de
plus en plus d'utilisateurs un zapping
toutes les 30 secondes année après année
toutefois la famille est emportée dans
une pente glissante qui a pousse à
consommer petit à petit des contenus de
plus en plus polarisants voire de plus
en plus enragent et haineux envers
d'autres communautés exposé
quotidiennement à la normalisation
d'appels à la violence la famille
elle-même c'est radicalisée et en vient
à conclure que la démocratie dans lequel
elle vit n'est plus acceptable elle
souhaite faire taire la voix des
minorités il souhaite le retour d'un
dirigeant puissant pour rétablir l'ordre
dans la société il considère même que
ceux qui exigent encore le dialogue
menacent le pays et que le pouvoir doit
être repris sur les autorités corrompues
par le vote ou celui-ci cela est
nécessaire par la force
de plus en plus l'exemple de
l'autoritarisme chinois voulez-vous à
dissidentes ne polluent pas l'espace
public ceci ressemble à un exemple à
suivre selon la famille après tout
toutes les images que la famille voit
représente une nation chinoise unie
ordonnée et prospère ou des fêtes sont
régulièrement organisées à la gloire du
pays
comme vous l'aurez peut-être deviné la
dystopie informationnelle qui introduit
cette vidéo est en fait une analogie
avec les services du réseau social Tik
Tok mais donc faisons le point
rapidement sur Tik Tok à moins que vous
ne débarquez d'un univers parallèle vous
savez certainement que Tik Tok est un
réseau social qui gagne énormément en
popularité au cours de ces dernières
années sur Tik Tok il y a surtout des
vidéos verticales de courte durée
souvent entre 15 secondes et une minute
même s'il est possible de mettre en
ligne des vidéos plus longues TikTok a
été lancé en 2016 dans sa version
chinoise où il s'appelle do Yin missila
ensuite été commercialisé à travers le
monde d'ailleurs le lien entre Tik Tok
et dwin est assez étrange alors que les
deux plateformes ont la même interface
les contenus de l'un ne peuvent pas être
accédés par l'autre et vice versa par
ailleurs de Yin est une application bien
plus complète puisqu'il permet notamment
par exemple de réserver des hôtels enfin
soulignons une fonctionnalité
potentiellement dérangeante de douille à
savoir la recherche de vidéos par visage
dans un pays où la BU de la
reconnaissance faciale par les autorités
et déjà très préoccupante ainsi devine
capable de retrouver les vidéos ou un
individu apparaît simplement à partir
d'une photo de cet individu ou dit
autrement d'où Yin est en train de
concevoir une base de données d'images
qui permet d'identifier tous ceux qui
sont apparus dans un contenu douillet
voilà qui va permettre de facilement
retrouver des contenus compromettants
sur beaucoup et ça c'est un peu flippant
juridiquement parlant Tik Tok et doen
appartiennent à une entreprise appelée
byte tens et fait étonnant byte Dance
est incorporé dans les îles Caïmans
visiblement même les dirigeants chinois
aiment l'évasion fiscale pardon je
voulais dire l'optimisation fiscale bon
par contre le siège social lui est bien
à Beijing la capitale chinoise Bight
dance développe d'autres plateformes
notamment tout Yao une plateforme de
recommandation personnalisée de site
d'actualité dehors je ne sais pas trop
qui a écrit la page Wikipédia sur toute
Tao mais la page insiste beaucoup sur le
machine learning très sophistiqué
développé et déployé pour cette
recommandation aujourd'hui Tik Tok c'est
le réseau social qui explose en
populariser surtout parmi les jeunes en
2020 Tik Tok a ainsi dépassé les deux
milliards de téléchargements sur mobile
et alors que la fraction d'adolescent
américain utilisant Facebook et Twitter
a chuté au cours de la dernière demi
décennie Tik Tok a pris le dessus sur
Instagram et snapchat pour devenir le
deuxième réseau social le plus utilisé
derrière YouTube et même le plus utilisé
chez les enfants ceci dit Tik Tok n'est
pas qu'une application de jeûne des gens
de tout âge utilisent la plateforme de
façon cruciale loin de l'imaginaire
collectif selon lequel Tik Tok n'aura
que des vidéos de danse Tik Tok joue un
rôle de plus en plus central dans la
diffusion de l'information selon une
étude du purisarch Institute alors que
la fraction d'utilisateur de Twitter qui
suivent régulièrement l'actualité sur
Twitter baisse et idem pour Facebook
Edith et YouTube les utilisateurs de Tik
Tok vont de plus en plus s'informer sur
le monde directement via l'application
de Tik Tok autrement dit la télécommande
de Tik Tok auparavant utilisé surtout
pour zapper vers des chaînes de
divertissement semblent de plus en plus
utilisés pour zapper vers des chaînes
d'information et ça ça devrait vous
paraître terrifiant d'autant que cette
athlète Tik Tok cet algorithme de
recommandation qui choisit quelle vidéo
diffuser à quelle utilisateur à quel
moment cette télécommande est vraiment
beaucoup plus puissante encore sur Tik
Tok qu'elle ne laisse sur des
plateformes comme YouTube Facebook ou
Twitter en effet sur Tik Tok par défaut
il n'y a pas de notion de vidéo sur
laquelle cliquez l'algorithme de
recommandation nous avons sur téléphone
zap et joue la vidéo suivante sans que
l'utilisateur d'entreprenne quelle
action que ce soit l'algorithme de Tik
Tok est surpuissant et ça ça devrait
susciter énormément de curiosités et
d’attention pour cet algorithme comment
est-il programmé quel est son objectif
et qui décide de cet objectif qui a le
pouvoir d'exploiter le pouvoir
monumental de la zapette de Tik Tok
alors byzen si une entreprise privée et
on pourrait croire que dès lors elle est
indépendante du Parti communiste chinois
c'est en tout cas ce que Tik Tok affirme
mais bien sûr faute d'audit des
infrastructures informationnelles de Tik
Tok les autorités américaines sont peu
convaincus par les déclarations de
TikTok et quand on sait à quel point
même les entreprises de pays
démocratiques mentent y compris à des
scientifiques qui acceptent leurs
mensonges il y a en effet de quoi être
très dubitatif d'autant que les enjeux
géopolitiques sur lesquels on reviendra
sont absolument énormes pour bien se les
représenter il est instructif de garder
en tête un chiffre partagé et publié par
l'Institut de recherche stratégique de
l’école militaire en France 20 millions
de Chinois seraient ainsi payés par les
autorités chinoises pour produire de la
désinformation dont 2 millions à temps
plein qui plus est le cas de jackma
expédiche d'Alibaba et cinquième plus
grande fortune de Chine et
particulièrement inquiétante cet homme
d'affaires bien connu pour ses
déclarations contestataires de la ligne
directrice du parti unique de la Chine
mystérieusement disparu d'octobre 2020 à
janvier 2021 et bizarrement il est
devenu beaucoup moins critique du Parti
communiste chinois ensuite et on
pourrait également citer le cas de la
joueuse de tennis Peng Shui et de la
journaliste one shrekin mais le cas de
Jacquemin en particulier semble en fait
représentatif d'une plus grande
attention donnée par le gouvernement
chinois aux entreprises du numérique
chinoise et pas l'entreprise qui
développe Tik Tok ne fait pas exception
ainsi en 2021 John gaming PDG de byted
dance et deuxièmement plus riche de
Chine démissionne à l'âge de seulement
38 ans ce qui paraît assez étrange en
avril 2021 le fonds d'investissement sur
Internet et de Chine une entreprise
étatique de l'administration de
cyberespace de Chine a acheté des parts
de by sense ce qui lui a permis de
placer un membre officiel du
gouvernement ou Shanghai dans le conseil
d'administration de bytens puis en 2022
le gouvernement chinois a lui-même
racheté départ de by tennis enfin suite
à des éléments de plus en plus
compromettants en novembre 2022 Tik Tok
a fini par que le personnel en Chine
pouvait bel et bien accéder aux données
des utilisateurs européens et il en est
sans doute de même des données
d'utilisateurs américains ceci dit Tik
Tok persiste à affirmer que le
gouvernement de figiping n'a pas accès à
ces données faut-il y croire
pour les wigours 88% ça nous rappelle un
score d'élection soviétique mais
justement la Chine n'aura pas
nécessairement besoin de faire de la
censure à l'ancienne en supprimant les
vidéos qui ne vont pas dans son sens il
lui suffira de simplement donner plus de
visibilité aux vidéos qui vendent dans
son sens la masse faisant les autres
vidéos seront naturellement
invisibilisés dans le flux cette
capacité d'une puissance à pousser des
récits qui l'arrangent à l'échelle
planétaire a déjà aujourd'hui et aura
encore plus demain une énorme influence
sur tous les affrontements géopolitiques
le fait de pousser à l'étranger des
récits qui nous arrangent et qui
déstabilisent les régimes adversaires à
un nom il s'agit de la guerre cognitive
cognitive warfare en anglais et c'est
exactement ce à quoi le président de
Taïwan fait référence lorsqu'il en
accusait la Chine en septembre 2022 en
disant d'elle qu'elle avait également
mené une guerre cognitive en utilisant
de fausses informations pour perturber
l'esprit des gens pour fragiliser la la
solution de Taïwan il semble que la
Chine est par exemple diffusée de
l'information visant à faire croire à
Taïwan et aux alliés des États-Unis que
l'armée américaine ne peut pas aider à
la défense de Taïwan encore une fois on
a là une énième version de la vieille
stratégie qui consiste à démobiliser le
camp adverse comme quand Trump a
convaincu des gens qui penchaient plus
tôt en faveur d'Hillary Clinton de ne
pas aller voter en 2016 Tik Tok sera
peut-être une arme surpuissante dans les
guerres cognitives que le régime chinois
mènera demain peut-être Tik Tok est-elle
à la guerre cognitive ce que la bombe
nucléaire fut à la guerre
conventionnelle en tous les cas on a
affaire avec Tik Tok à l'émergence d'une
arme encore plus élaborée et puissante
que les outils utilisés pour l'ingérance
russe au travers de Facebook dans les
élections américaines de 2016 c'est
quand même plus pratique de répandre
discrètement de la désinformation quand
on est propriétaire du réseau sur
laquelle on la diffuse que lorsqu'il
s'agit de celui de l'adversaire c'est
bien plus efficace de faire de
l'ingérence dès lors qu'on a le contrôle
total de la super télécommande de
l'application sur les citoyens
utilisateurs des pays que vous voulez
affaiblir passent 1h30 par jour en
moyenne et ce contrôle de la super
télécommande la Chine peut s'en servir
pour renforcer sa position géopolitique
à l'échelle planétaire sur tout un tas
de sujets par exemple elle pourrait
décider de donner une caisse de
résonance au contenu qui affaiblissent
les démocraties au contenu qui donne une
bonne image de la Chine auprès des
marchés asiatiques et africains au
contenu qui prétendent que quand même la
politique du Zéro covid c'était un sacré
succès pour l'instant l'application Tik
Tok se contente de suggérer innocemment
les recherches vaccins covid blessures
vaccin covid vérité vaccin covid HIV et
vaccin covid avertissement à toute
personne qui a commencé la recherche
vaccin covid mais à notre sujet
planétaire pourrait également être
massivement influencé par la
télécommande Tik Tok pour moi le sujet
dans tous les journaux devraient parler
en permanence
comme le disait Greta en 2016 je veux
bien sûr parler du changement climatique
la Chine pouvez très bien grâce à Tik
Tok minimiser sa responsabilité dans le
changement climatique or quand on sait
que la Chine émettrait plus de GES que
tous les pays développés réunis on
réalise que si l'envie prend à la Chine
de pousser un récit comme quoi les
centrales électriques au charbon c'est
pas si pire pour le changement
climatique la lutte climatique déjà
moribonde risque de le sentir passer et
les stratégies et les types de contenu
que la Chine peut pousser pour améliorer
sa position géopolitique sur le
changement climatique grâce à sa super
télécommande sont innombrables elle peut
bien sûr promouvoir des récits qui
atténueraient sa responsabilité d'un
changement climatique mais elle pourrait
aussi diffuser des discours exagérants
ça participation à la lutte climatique
ou des récits dénigrants l'action
climatique des autres pays où on peut
aussi pousser le narratif comme quoi le
changement climatique c'est pas si réel
que ça par exemple selon le même papier
que pour le covid l’auto complétion de
TiK ToK on regarde plutôt dans le sens
de cette dernière option puisqu'à la
recherche changement climatique Tik Tok
va suggérer la recherche changement
climatique 10 banques et changement
climatique n'existe pas et d'ailleurs
pourquoi choisir une stratégie
particulière plutôt qu'une autre puisque
ça n'est pas vraiment une télécommande
super puissante sur laquelle la Chine a
le contrôle mais un milliard et 700
millions de télécommandes autant que
d'utilisateurs
alors bien sûr il y a deux grandes
marques de télécommande l'une plutôt
adaptée au marché chinois et l'autre
plutôt au marché extérieur mais ça reste
le même fabricant pour le milliard 7 de
télécommande et quand on a le contrôle
sur toute cette télécommandes pourquoi
dès lors ne pas appliquer toutes les
stratégies en même temps en fonction des
publics on peut tout à fait continuer à
œuvrer pour sa propre indépendance
énergétique avec des contenus en faveur
de l'énergie solaire auprès des citoyens
chinois tout en démobilisant les
citoyens d'autres États sur les sujets
de leur indépendance énergétique c'est
déjà une stratégie qui avait employer la
Russie avec Russia Today en 2021 sur la
vaccination en faisant la promotion du
vaccin et en dénonçant les conspirations
vaccin à l'intérieur de la Russie et en
faisant à peu près strictement l'inverse
à l'extérieur sauf que là ça sera plus
facile plus discret et à plus grande
échelle bien sûr il s'agit pour
l'instant plus ou moins de fiction avec
quand même sacrément basé sur des faits
réels mais le fait que ça soit même
envisageable devrait tout et tous nous
mettre en alerte écarlate parce que nous
devons avoir conscience que la censure
algorithmique de Tik Tok risque d'être
bien plus discrète insidieuse et
beaucoup moins évidente à détecter et à
combattre que celle d'un humain sur C8
et elle se fera à l'échelle planétaire
c'est dire au combien laisser la
maîtrise de cette super télécommande à
la Chine et périlleux climatiquement et
juste globalement en fait parce que
comme l'expliquer les au début de cette
vidéo la télécommande de Tik Tok est
bien plus puissante que celle des autres
plateformes on trouvait déjà effrayant
que 70% du contenu regardé sur Youtube
c'est à dire 700 millions d'heures par
jour et a été recommandé par
l'algorithme de recommandation d'une
entité privée dans le seul but est de
faire le plus d'argent possible comment
ne pas être révolté à l'idée qu'avec
l'énorme succès de TiK ToK on a en fait
quasi 100% du contenu regardé qui est
recommandé par un agrume de
recommandation complètement maîtrisé par
un État autoritaire dans le président
assume qu'il veut orienter l'opinion
publique dominante en recourant à de
nouveaux moyens et perfectionner le
système de gestion intégré des sites
Internet de manière à créer un
cyberespace sain et propre pour moi les
agrumes de recommandation sont à
l'organisme vivant humanité ce que les
biais cognitifs sont à l'individu humain
il filtre l'information sachant ça
est-il vraiment raisonnable pour
l'organisme vivant humanité de laisser
la télécommande de son attention à une
entité comme Tik Tok essayez de nous
penser comme un gigantesque organisme
vivant qui doit tenter d'organiser ses
flux d'informations pour parvenir à
traverser vivant à 21e siècle qui risque
de nous mettre durement à l'épreuve
c'est précisément plus de ça dont je
parle sur ma chaîne donc n'hésitez pas à
regarder quelques vidéos et à vous
abonner si ça vous intéresse en
attendant je laisse les parler de ça
justement ce problème que la gouvernance
algorithmique de ce gigantesque
organisme vivant dont nous sommes tous
une cellule devrait tous et toutes nous
poser j'en profite pour signaler que
Jean-Loup avait précédemment une
chronique dans arrêt sur image mais que
celle-ci a été interrompue parce que
selon les producteurs Jean-Loup avait
fait le tour de la question des
algorithmes de recommandation
comme vous l'aurez peut-être compris en
me suivant je considère que ce sujet est
en fait plus important et plus complexe
que d'autres sujets également importants
et complexes comme par exemple celui du
changement climatique et donc affirmer
qu'on peut avoir fait le tour de la
question ça me paraît être une grave
erreur de jugement imaginez un peu qu'on
vous dise ah non sur TF1 on va arrêter
de parler de changement climatique parce
qu'on a fait le tour de la question pas
sûr que ça passerait bien auprès des
écolos
trop souvent à mon goût la tension est
portée sur les données extraites par Tik
Tok et oui en un sens Tik Tok est un
spyware redoutable c'est-à-dire un
logiciel qui permet la surveillance et
qui est installé sur le téléphone de
milliards d'humains à travers la planète
mais si Tic-Toc me paraît absolument
terrifiant c'est beaucoup plus parce
qu'il s'agit d'une télécommande qui
contrôle l'exposition informationnelle
quotidienne de ces milliards d'humains
qui plus est cette télécommande est
extrêmement opaque il est extrêmement
difficile de comprendre comment Tik Tok
organise le flux de l'information est-ce
que Tik Tok des recommandes les
reportages sur les wigos c'est dire à ce
qui diminue artificiellement leur
recommandation ce qu'on appelle aussi le
Shadow ban qu'en est-il des vidéos sur
le changement climatique nos machines
est de plus en plus responsable TikTok
amplifie-t-il les appels à la haine des
mouvements d'extrême droite donne-t-il
plus de visibilité à des clashs et à la
désinformation aujourd'hui il est
impossible de fournir des réponses
quantitatives à ces questions et cette
opacité renforce le pouvoir de nuisances
des autorités chinoises qui peuvent
ainsi nuire au démocratie que leurs
interventions ne soient identifiables
Pia les controverses sur la modération
jouit un rôle de distraction stratégique
une stratégie du gouvernement chinois
bien documenté autrement dit le sujet de
la modération attire toute l'attention
des médias et politiciens et des
régulateurs si bien que les nouvelles
régulations comme le digital ici actes
qu'on appelle aussi le dessin cet acte
de l'Union européenne comporte de
nombreuses restrictions et exigences
vis-à-vis de la modération mais ignore
complètement le sujet de la
recommandation comme je n'avais pu le
constater quand j'ai été invité dans un
comité d'experts à l'arcom le notoriété
pour la régulation de la communication
de visuels énumériques qui sont ces
appliquer le DSA en France
malheureusement par voie de conséquence
l'audit est des algorithmes de
recommandation est aujourd'hui gravement
sous-financé et sous-valorisé si bien
qu’il est quasiment inexistant alors
qu'on parle là d'un enjeu de sécurité
nationale or les moyens nécessaires pour
des audits adéquats sont énormes
d'autant que les télécommandes de Tik
Tok sont ultra personnalisés les
recommandations faites à un compte
TikTok ne sont en fait que très peu
représentatifs des recomm
en fait la principale préoccupation à
avoir vis-à-vis de Tik Tok ne devrait
pas être les recommandations que Tik Tok
fait aujourd'hui la principale
préoccupation ça devrait davantage être
celle de la gouvernance de cet
télécommande Tik Tok qui aujourd'hui est
demain aura le pouvoir de reprogrammer
cette télécommande à qui sommes-nous en
train de céder le pouvoir de la gestion
du flux de l'information à travers le
monde plus que comme une attaque
frontale sur la démocratie Tik Tok
ressemble aujourd'hui davantage un
cheval de Troie une offrande distrayante
qui pourrait un jour déclencher
l'effondrement des démocraties
alors cette vidéo se concentre sur Tik
Tok parce que c'est un exemple
particulièrement frappant mais les
préoccupations que nous avons soulevées
ici s'applique en fait pour toutes les
télécommandes les plus puissantes du
monde qui contrôle les télécommandes de
Youtube Facebook Instagram Twitter et
LinkedIn qui contrôleront ces
télécommandes demain et qui contrôle le
rond ce qui contrôle ces télécommandes
vous le savez certainement Twitter a
récemment été racheté par Elon Musk un
milliardaire qui n'a pas attardé à
prendre des mesures qui inquiètent
fortement tous ceux qui s'intéressent à
la qualité de l'information au
cyber-harcèlement et à prolifération
dangereuse des discours de haine Twitter
appartient par ailleurs en partie à
défendre liés à la monarchie de l’arabie
saoudite et en partie au Qatar deux pays
connus pour leurs abus récurrents des
droits humains et pour leurs
utilisations de logiciels malveillants
qui plus est des employés de Twitter ont
déjà été inculpés pour espionnage au
profit de l’arabie Saoudite télégram lui
as son siège social aux Émirats razzuni
très probablement très impliqué dans des
massacres horribles notamment en au
Yémen et en Éthiopie qui plus est
contrairement à ceux qui souhait a
annoncé telegram n'est pas chiffré en
tout cas pas par défaut et surtout
telegram n'est pas open source et pas
libre non plus ou du moins seul la
partie frontaine c'est à dire
l'application que vous téléchargez est
Open Source cependant ce que telegramme
fait de vos données non chiffrées est
totalement opaque et s'appuie sur des
logiciels propriétaires inconnus
Facebook lui semble avoir suivi les
exigences des actionnaires depuis
plusieurs années ce qui les a conduits à
prioriser encore et encore les profits à
la sécurité des populations entières
désormais victimes de génocide notamment
au Myanmar au tigré et en Inde par
ailleurs le code libre de Mastodon a été
détourné par Donald Trump qu'il a
exploité pour créer son propre réseau
trouve social un véritable nid de
radicalisation ou au lieu de retweeter
les messages des autres vous pouvez les
retrouver à l'instar des algorithmes
open source de Deep learning qui peuvent
être utilisés pour produire des deep
fakes de désinformations et du
cyber-harcèlement ces solutions sont des
armes que les entités malveillantes
peuvent réutiliser à mauvaise escient
développer ses armes qui clairement
seront utilisées ces acteurs et qui
seront ensuite impossibles à gouverner
ça me paraît extrêmement dangereux enfin
Google a littéralement propulsé Raoult
via sa télécommande ce qui a
probablement conduit à des milliers de
morts additionnels du covid mais aussi
et surtout à une normalisation
dangereuse du rejet des autorités et à
une perte de confiance pour les
instituts publics et les scientifiques
qui plus est Google a viré son équipe
d'éthique et trompe la communauté
scientifique en désinformant sur la
sécurité de ses algorithmes le tout pour
accélérer le déploiement beaucoup trop
précipité de nouvelles télécommandes
toujours mieux personnalisées mais aussi
indirectement manipulable par des
campagnes de troll plus généralement à
l'air des spyers notamment à priori
déployer dans l'application du sommet
cop27 en Égypte tout système d’influence
majeure contre les par une poignée
d'individus seulement peut en fait être
sous le contrôle d'entité malveillante
qui exploite la menace ou le chantage
pour contrôler ses individus en fait
cette préoccupation dépasse le cadre des
télécommandes du numérique puisque de
nombreux chefs d'État semblent avoir été
ainsi surveiller depuis des années y
compris Emmanuel Macron et listrot
l'ex-première ministre britannique de
quoi se demander d'où viennent certaines
des propositions que ces personnes ont
faites dès lors la sécurité nationale
semble exiger le contrôle décentralisé
et non unilatéral de toute télécommande
de flux massifs d'information à travers
le web ou dit autrement il est urgent
d'établir une gouvernance collaborative
du web et j'en profite pour signaler le
fait que ce n'est pas ce que propose
Mastodon c'est alternative open source
est libre à Twitter qui propose plutôt à
chacun de créer sa propre gouvernance
mais qui ne pourra s'appliquer qu'à
l'ensemble des utilisateurs ayant
accepté de se joindre à la structure
ainsi gouvernée en fait la conception
même de Mastodon encourage les bulles de
filtres comme trousse social et Gap
social et favorise ainsi l'émergence de
nid de radicalisation responsable de
leur propre modération et qui seront
donc impossibles à gouverner pour des
individus externes assez communauté si
ce n'est par la loi mais bon en parlant
de la loi ça sera déjà bien de
l'appliquer aux publicités ciblées par
exemple en fait cet exemple montre que
décentraliser la gouvernance ne suffit
pas il faut aussi que cette gouvernance
s'applique à l'ensemble des utilisateurs
pour éviter que ceux qui refusent
d'entendre parler des changements
climatiques ou de compassion envers les
populations de vulnérables ne puisse
s'isoler se radicaliser et ainsi
représenter une menace pour ces
populations vulnérables ainsi les
algodes de recommandations ne sont pas
un problème individuel ce qui aurait
commandé à des millions de Russes
menacent la sécurité de millions
ukrainien en fait plus généralement la
gouvernance est un problème différent de
celui de la propriété même des logiciels
libres peuvent être corrompus par une
gouvernance unilatérale mais alors qui
existe-t-il aujourd'hui pour gouverner
collaborativement des télécommandes et
bien à ma connaissance et j'ai quand
même pas mal épluché la littérature
scientifique à ce sujet il existe qu'un
seul projet déployé de gouvernance
collaborative avancé et sécurisé à
savoir le projet tournesol et bon je ne
vais pas vous refaire le pitch de ce
qu'est tournesol mais j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aide à mieux comprendre le
besoin auquel tournesol répond ici vous
aussi vous pensez que gouverner
collaborativement les télécommandes
pratique pour la sécurité nationale et
la paix à travers le monde je vous
encourage à participer à notre projet en
créant un compte et en comparant des
vidéos pour programmer collaborativement
la télécommande tournesol les
télécommandes dont on a tellement parlé
dans notre livre Le fable le chantier
avec elmadian Hamdi c'était les
commandes sont d'ores et humaine et
surpuissante des outils comme tournesol
semblent indispensables pour enfin les
gouverner collaborativement
j'espère vous avoir convaincu que dès à
présent et plus encore dans les années à
venir la télécommande de Tik Tok est une
arme de destruction massive dans la
guerre cognitive de l'information qui
oppose les superpuissances mondiales une
menace qui me paraît plus terrifiante
encore que le changement climatique et
les menaces nucléaires de Poutine de
façon toutefois terriblement frustrante
le danger que représente cette
télécommande est une énorme mute news
rares sont ceux qui parlent de Tik Tok
comme d'un danger et plus rare encore
ceux qui s'arrêtent davantage sur
l'algorithme de recommandations que sur
l'extraction des données personnelles et
encore dans cette vidéo nous n'avons
parlé que des risques d'utilisation
malveillantes de la télécommande de
TikTok en pratique cette malveillance
n'est même pas nécessaire pour nuire à
la société Tik Tok a déjà des
conséquences dramatiques sur la capacité
d'attention des utilisateurs ainsi que
sur leur santé mentale et sur leur
productivité dépend que l'accès à
douille la version chinoise de Tik Tok
et restreint en Chine ainsi les enfants
de moins de 14 ans n'ont droit qu'à 40
minutes par jour sur dojin dès lors
sachant toutes ces conséquences néfastes
de Tik Tok et le danger que représente
l'accès qu'à la dictature chinoise à la
télécommande de Tik Tok il est urgent de
sérieusement questionner l'adoption
massive de ce réseau social ramener des
gens sur Tik Tok c'est augmenter la
dépendance informationnelle de toutes
nos sociétés autorités chinoises de
manière plus insidieuse encore que la
dépendance de l'Allemagne au gaz russe
ou au marché chinois Tik Tok n'a rien de
cool c'est une arme c'est un danger
sociétal ceci étant dit boycotter
individuellement tikloque ne suffira pas
après tout tikkok n'affecte pas que ses
utilisateurs en biaisant l'attention de
ces utilisateurs Tik Tok est une menace
pour toute la société et en particulier
pour la priorisation des enjeux
importants et pour la prise de décision
collective par ailleurs audité Tik Tok
ne suffira pas non plus même si ces
audits sont nécessaires pour mieux
comprendre ce que TikTok recommande
aujourd'hui il ne nous diront rien de ce
que tikkok recommandera dans le futur
une fois son infiltration dans les
démocraties réussie et au moment où
shigiprine décidera d'exploiter cette
infiltration pour modifier sa
télécommande et la faire amplifier
massivement la désinformation et la
haine dans les démocraties mais alors
que faire faut-il interdire TikTok comme
l'un de la fée et comme certains membres
de la Commission fédérale des
communications américaines le suggèrent
quitte à faire des millions
d'utilisateurs voire des milliards
d'utilisateurs mécontents ou peut-on
envisager un rachat de Tik Tok en Europe
voire une nationalisation du service
proposé par le réseau social il me
semble y avoir urgent à prendre des
décisions fortes pour protéger les
démocraties cependant j'insiste à
nouveau dessus le problème de la
sécurité des réseaux sociaux notamment
contre la désinformation le harcèlement
et la haine et plus encore quand il
s'agit de mettre en avant l'information
de qualité tout ça ne sera pas résolu
tant qu'on n'exige pas au préalable une
gouvernance collaborative transparente
et auditable des télécommandes de ces
réseaux sociaux et ça ça requiert au
préalable des outils efficaces et
sécurisés de gouvernance collaborative
de ces télécommandes bref ce dont nous
avons avant tout besoin pour sécuriser
nos démocraties c'est il me semble de
sécuriser développer et promouvoir des
plateformes comme tournesol et pour y
arriver très concrètement aujourd'hui on
a surtout besoin besoin de plus
attention de plus de contribution et de
plus de financement donc encore une fois
je vous invite vivement à vous informer
sur notre projet à le promouvoir auprès
de votre entourage et de votre milieu
professionnel à fournir des comparaisons
de vidéos pour alimenter notre base de
données et pour identifier plus de
vidéos de qualité à contribuer au
développement open source de notre code
libre et à donner à l'association
tournesol voir à appeler des fonds et
des fondations à envisager le
financement d'un web enfin gouverné de
manière multilatérale collaborative et
sécurisé j'espère vous avoir convaincu
que le futur de nos sociétés en dépend